bien ayer
la entrevista colectiva yo les dije
que toda la elecciones
pero no siempre es posible
hay una cosa en mi vida que
me motiva me estimula
y me hace Renacer cada día
la cree
nada pasa por casualidad durante toda
esta campaña
nosotros estuvimos liderando las
encuestas de opinión
pedazo con los caballitos a pesar de que
algunos no querían que ganáramos
y yo sé que nosotros vamos a ganar las
elecciones
[Aplausos]
eso
para nosotros es solo una prolongación
quiero decir que el comportamiento de
esta empresa en estas elecciones
quiero dar
felicitaciones a todas las personas que
estuvieron presentes independientemente
no tenemos problemas las personas eligen
Quiero agradecer al pueblo brasileño
por tener ese valor
para validar bien lo que está pasando
hoy
y lo que está pasando Hace cuatro años
atrás
Hace cuatro años
yo estaba considerado
como un ser humano que estaba fuera de
la política
que la gente volvería que nosotros
volveríamos con más fuerza quién iba a
decirlo
para derrotar
lo que el pueblo brasileño tenía otras
centenas de
liderazgos
Y ustedes saben que nuestro país está
peor ahora
sabe que la cualidad de vida no está
bien Ahora que el empleo no está bien
que la salud No está bien y que nosotros
queremos recuperar este país
y nuestra impresión de Cara a la Esfera
internacional por lo tanto para
desgracia de algunos
tenemos 30 días para ganar
r para ir a las calles para hablar con
la gente
para conectar con la sociedad brasileña
para hacer un debate cara a cara con el
presidente de la república
continuar contando mentiras
porque no quiere decirle la verdad al
pueblo brasileño
aquel debate No valió mucho
la gente estaba extraña
vamos a esperar al segundo turno para
poder debatir solo con él las
comparaciones
del Brasil que él construyó y el que yo
construí nuestro periodo de gobierno
con lo que el pueblo vive hoy
quiero decirles que
voy a luchar por esta campaña
voy a tener
voy a estar acompañado de los míos
pero vamos a esperar hasta 30 de octubre
cuando es el aniversario
para
la Grande Victoria que necesitaba en
[Aplausos]
las elecciones se dieron exactamente un
27 de octubre
Entonces tenemos que centrarnos en la
campaña
que tiene que trabajar un poco más
a nuestros compañeros nuestros aliados
para que tengan más debates
tienen que conversar más con las
personas y con la sociedad brasileña de
lo que tenemos que convencerlos de lo
que estamos proponiendo
cuando Tus fuerzas Tenemos que hablar
con las otras fuerzas políticas que nos
disputan en las elecciones y lo
siguiente la lucha continúa hasta la
victoria final
[Aplausos]
nosotros Nosotros
Esperamos contar con el apoyo
de cada uno de ustedes
es incansable lo que ustedes hacen con
los candidatos
voy a intentar arreglar el Brasil
nuestro compañero
Daddy fue para el segundo turno
somos muy amigos
será efectivamente
[Aplausos]
Sao Paulo será un grande palco de
nacional y Estatal
la confrontación de ideas de debates
de propuestas para la sociedad
para hacer todo lo que sea posible
los dos juntos vamos a ganar en Sao
Paulo
por eso necesito una cosa de ustedes
describimos lo que la gente habla aquí
después pueden publicarlo
estoy a su entera disposición
ahora vamos para el paulista Y a partir
de ahora
Prepárense porque vamos a trabajar mucho
con la candidata aquí
ella puede cantar
ella puede subir para cantar un poco
es una tregua apenas
son 30 días en los que usted puede
trabajar un poco más para convencer al
pueblo
brasileño
el día 30 el 27
28 el 28 de octubre
la gente nosotros podemos conmemorar
el día 30
que nadie se olvide el día 30 nosotros
vamos
a estar en el parque otra vez
de corazón Muchas gracias a ustedes y
muchas gracias al pueblo brasileño
[Aplausos]
nunca gané una lección en la primera
vuelta
la última fue en el segundo turno
Pero lo importante aquí en la segunda
vuelta
son las propuestas para la sociedad para
construir
una red de alianzas y apoyos
para mostrarselas al pueblo
y demostrar Quién va a gobernar en este
país vamos a ello gente
somos un beso
para ustedes de corazón para todos los
paulistas
[Aplausos]
[Música]